text or Internet traffic the
cutting-edge security technologies
ensuring strong and reliable encryption
between your device and the VPN server
nor VPN is based away from you and us
jurisdictions and is not required to
collect your personal data nor
information the cyber secretes
automatically blocks suspicious websites
so that no malware can infect your
device if you need an extra high level
of online security and privacy use
double VPN to encrypt your Internet
traffic not once but twice with a single
node VPN account you can protect up to
six devices at the same time nor VPN is
available for Windows Mac OS Android and
iOS start protecting yourself on the web
at North VPN dot org slash fire and
blood or use called forum blood and save
66% hey guys in this video Murray in the
second part of a seemingly legit outline
for episode 5 of the final season the
first part Saucer second sense in front
of John Snow it was basically sensor
john so sensor decided to drink a
poisoned wine on search disorders
sacrificing herself in order to save
john from being brutally killed it was
quite heartbreaking but unfortunately i
have to warn you that this episode sees
many more deaths and i have to warn you
that this list includes some fans
favourite characters the first half also
sustaining a life-threatening situation
the same that resulted with her mother
dying as well as johnson Tyrion's as
well it's going to be interesting to see
how Dana's pregnancy and childbirth
situation will wrap up will Denny die
along with a child will one of them die
and the others survive or perhaps both
survive we'll find out in this second
part of the episode in the first part we
also witnessed a huge meeting at the
dragon pit in which Ari announced that
she's going to try and save John from
the dungeons of the red keep using the
secret passage that she found out way
back in the first season while chasing a
cat before I start let me warn you once
again that this leaked outline does seem
to be legit so if you don't want
anything to be potentially spoiled it's
time for you to close this video in case
you haven't seen part 1 of this episode
I highly suggest you to do so and then
come back to watch this video we're
still at a huge meeting at the dragon
pit it states that Brienne enters the
tent she says that she can't find Sansa
no one has seen or heard of her since
the morning Arya asked his brain if he
can see where their sister is when poses
with the sadness on his face bring real
story and everyone else that he saw
Cersei killing their sister Aria doesn't
want to accept this she says it can't be
your visions are not true Ginji hugs
sorry and tries to calm her down but
Arya pushes him off everyone grows
furious especially the Hound brain
continues by saying Cersei now plans to
have all of us the living and the dead
son streets of King's Landing that's why
she let us inside and the battle starts
she intends to burn the entire set it
down with wildfire we need to find a way
to stop her
that was says it was a trap Tara nods in
shock and says viola in a trap
Tyrion has brain if he'd seen where the
netting is and if there is enough time
for them to leave and seek refuge
somewhere else
Brennan's words with I'm afraid not if
you leave this city we're going to be
slaughtered we might not be able to sing
but nothing is army are just outside the
city walls and if we stay here we are
going to be burned alive
Tyrael replies on each aria responds
with not if I get to Cersei first Jaime
then replies to Aria even if you somehow
managed to sneak into the castle you
will not be able to pass the mountain no
one is arya looks towards the hound lord
glower says if only the dragon queen was
here to structure severe of dragons and
burn her live inside her heap o a Jaime
responds that there's wildfire beneath
the red keep to and Tyrion continues by
saying it'll result in the entire red
key being burnt down along with Jon Snow
in the heat of meeting the here horn
being blown the nat king and his army of
the dead have attacked the city walls
the battle for King's Landing has
started in part one of this episode we
witness senses death and now brain
informs Arya and everyone else about it
Jimmy saying that there are caches of
wildfire beneath the red keep to and
therefore there has been this part of
the outline also hints that aria in the
count will likely use the secret passage
into the red keep dungeons to free Jon
Snow and then proceed up the stairs to
kill Cersei making the cool game ball
very likely to happen as well in a heat
of a meeting the dead at a King's
Landing
it says that the unsullied the gone
accompany the Lannisters the Ironborn
the Tully free army with a small amount
of the northerners and the Trekkie give
a good fight the army of the dead is not
able to bridge the city gates nor the
city walls are you accompanying it goes
ginji's center could gain and Brienne
rushes to the gates Fiona are admir
tally here Strickland Davos interior
enjoying the golden company the Ironborn
to the track and the tally Frey armies
on the walls then take the command Jaime
and Bronn lead Lannister's grey worm
leads the unsullied Lord glowering Lord
manually
the northerners to the city gates it's
only a matter of time until the gates
are breached
Qyburn inform Cersei the battle for
King's Landing has begun
Cersei orders the Wildfire under city
gates to be initiated and their way
allowed in I Kings army to fight a live
inside inside a capital circita sky burn
dead soon they will initiate wildfire
attack all over the city the city gate
has been obliterated by wildfire along
with the towers that once protected it
the skills small amount of whites bigger
amount of the gun company along with
their leader Harry Hoover on the towers
the army of the Dead rushes through the
Fallen city gates area goes dangerous
cynical game Brienne Jaime Brown great
warlord Glover and Lord man early with
the Lannisters then Sully the North
nurse tried to hold him this part has
also been confirmed by many leaked
photos as some of you may know for the
final season of Game of Thrones the
production for the very first time
instead of filming is landing scene
Cindy browning they decided to make a
huge King's Landing set in Belfast and
fill most of the scenes so why did they
build city buildings to resemble Surrey
they used for King's Landing all these
years instead of filming an actual
medieval towns as they usually do
that's because game utterance is not
allowed to burn cities to the ground as
you can see in this leaked photos the
set has been modified appear burned down
the huge bridge between demolish towers
the city gate has been obliterated and
the towers that once protected it have
fallen just like the outline states it
continues by stating that ghost Lord
Glover and Lord mannerly perished first
Yara dies on the city walls by saving
Theon during the battle the white swarm
Aria she fights back but is eventually
tackled by White's Ginji Brienne and
Jaime citizens start running towards
aria it's Jamie who saves Arya at the
last minute Jamie stabbed numerous times
in the process
Jamie collapses we seem dying in Brian's
arms Jamie's last words are I fulfilled
my promise this part of the outline sees
many main characters dying sure sing
another in the last dire wolf die as
well as ER sacrificing her life to save
Thea knee is going to be average said
but not as said has seen one of our most
favorite characters dying in such an
honourable manner
Jaime has fulfilled his promise stories
matter he protected his daughters as
best as he could and he even saved the
Aria with part of Ned Stark so maligne
still sort this Jamie's ending has been
foreshadowed back in season 5 episode 4
in the Tepes old brown eyes Jaime how
would he like to die and Jaime responded
with in the arms of the woman I love
that woman will be Brienne how do you
want to go
the Outland and stayed that night he
arrives with his undead dragon he starts
burning down huge portion of the capital
King's Landing Don first Tyrion orders
men to start firing scorpion sang Hazen
at King's dragon and to start carpooling
wildfire against his army there are no
bolts to be fired nor wildfire to be
catapulted it's all gone on starts his
orders the night king burning down huge
portion of the capital including King's
Landing dome using his and a dragon has
also been confirmed by many leaked
photos here you can see the King's
Landing dome that has been burned down
how can I know for sure that this is the
night King's doing rather than the
result of Cersei using wildfire and
burning down the entire city even though
burned King's Landing set would seem to
support hearing with Cersei burns down
the entire city the answer is no
wildfire is not a reason this part of
King's Landing set is being burned down
its dragon fire how do I know it's
simply due to the fact that the show
built the King's Landing said mainly to
do live power techniques it means that
some parts of the capital will be burned
down by a dragon as Dragon Fire in Game
of Thrones is portrayed by live
pyrotechnics basically sources plan to
have the living and the dead fight
inside King's Landing will come true but
you're burning them all with wildfire
will not or at least not yet
the net huge dragon that is responsible
for huge portion the capital being
burned down has also been spotted on
King's Landing set yes dragons are
visual effects magic mostly however when
performers have to interact with dragons
the number of methods are used to make
it work for example if Danny had to
touch the dragon's head and each arrow
head shaped object will do such as this
one using the Dragons for babies this is
the night King touching missourians head
in the last season if actor septa
actually mounted dragon part of its
spine has to be physically recreated
which is exactly what his massive
contraption on King's Landing set is
this massive contraption being on this
very same set means that nothing will at
some point is side to landing King's
Landing
perhaps in the final episode anyways the
all tendon states that we're back at
Dragonstone King Mirage or about the
necessary sacrifice there is required
for the Great War to be born tomorrow
tell Jared the only way for Danny to
survive is with the death of her unborn
child Jorah kill scheme are the nares
gives birth to twins everyone is alive
and well Jared tells Sam that he saved
his life twice now the battle for King's
Landing rages many soldiers as well as
innocent people died the night King
continues burning down King's Landing
that was dice the episode ends with a
shot of a secret passage into the red
keep we see Jamie with Nederland central
game with virus valent ring
this ending is coming as both a huge
surprise and as a popular theory finally
kind of coming true
Jimmy's died saving aria but he's now
heading to the red cape to kill his med
sister with the Hound the usual fan this
would seem pretty odd but a hardcore fan
of Game of Thrones I wouldn't say it's
not hot but it's definitely not coming
as a huge shock let's hear it again
Jamie has died by saving Arya and is at
the end of the episode seen approaching
the secret passage Arya was talking
about earlier on the meeting is
accompanied with the Hound and his
building needle or a sword unfortunately
this doesn't mean that Jaime has been
resurrected or anything like that he's
dead this is are you wearing Jamie's
face and building her own sword fighting
her way to the red cape as she announced
she would additionally it's mentioned
that the Hound wields widow's Vale
Jamie's Valyrian steel sword meaning
that upon Jamie's death he picked up his
sword and is now heading with Arya to
put an end to Cersei the popular theory
of Jamie killing his sister surged civil
kind of come true Jamie will likely kill
her but it's not real Jamie but darío
verón Jamie's face this is surely not
going to be like when our heroes Wohlers
face to kill the free family it's more
likely the target will firstly take off
Jamie's face to make Cersei suffer a bit
and then kill her earlier in the episode
Jamie told Arya dead she will not be
able to pass by the mountain and she
will not need to she's bringing
centrical game with her the game ball is
going down in the final episode their
heavy guy is the season 8 episode 5
leaked outline that was sent to me in
August last year months before Game of
Thrones started filming its final season
months before any leaked photos were
taken and yet it seems to be supported
by all the leaks that eventually
appeared